my favorite scene with him would have to
be
part when my arm gets ripped off
with the rise of shows like stranger
things and the umbrella academy
it might not be shocking to meet some
phenomenal young actors
but what is shocking is finding out just
how
young some of these stars are hollywood
has 12 year olds playing assassins and
eight-year-olds dealing with such mature
content we can't even imagine how they
were even allowed on the set
it's time to uncover some child stars
who were just way too young for their
roles
you're not sorry but you will be
millie bobby brown is probably one of
the best actresses of her generation
and it isn't surprising when you think
about how young she was when she got her
big break on a little show called
stranger things
millie was just 11 when she was cast as
11
and barely 12 when she began filming so
i was pretty nervous
to not have any hair that doesn't sound
too young
until you think about what kind of
character eleven was in season one
millie's character was someone who took
lives accidentally but still
who was tortured and who suffered some
intense loss
that's a lot for any preteen but the
duffer brothers admitted they didn't
even pay attention to their age
just that they were able to deliver a
very rich human experience
despite what age body they were in one
thing is for sure
she did a pretty epic job i know it's
just fantastic
millie bobby brown wasn't the only
youngling on the series
noah schnapp was and is the same age as
his co-star
when i was around like six years old i
knew i wanted to be on that stage i knew
i wanted to be an actor
ironically the two youngest of the
ensemble cast are the ones who had the
darkest storylines
noah played will byers who was kidnapped
stuck in the horror filled upside down
and had too many close calls when it
came to his life even preparing for
season 2 got dark for noah
he was 13 and reading stories about
possession so that he could really
understand will and get into character
that's some dark stuff it just makes me
feel like more of a freak
you're not a freak yeah i am
what teenager is able to pull off
playing a 58 year old man
you'd probably think no one until you
realize that aiden gallagher did
exactly that for his role as number five
in umbrella academy
while five looks like a teen he has the
mental state of a middle aged man
a 58 year old time traveling assassin
who gets stuck in his teenage body this
meant
fourteen-year-old aiden spent his time
on set plotting to save the world
taking down assassins and drinking a lot
of coffee
mckenna grace has been in mature roles
like annabelle
itanya and the haunting of hill house
however her role in the handmaid's tale
definitely wins for the role she is way
too young for
it was not my choice at just 14 she took
on esther keys
a child bride who has been through a
huge amount of abuse in her life
her parents wouldn't even allow her to
watch the series until she found out she
got the role
but mckenna being the professional she
is thinks the whole point of her role
was to make people uncomfortable
and said some people have had to go
through it so i wanted to make sure that
i did it right
isla johnston was the perfect young beth
harmon
but what we're truly not over is how
this 12 year old was able to convey
all the emotions of this damaged little
girl we all know beth had a horrific
childhood and dealt with self-medicating
and mental illness
two things no 12 year old should even
have to think about
it may just be acting but it's still
some pretty dark content
on the outside ginny and georgia might
look like some funny little comedy
but when you start peeling those layers
episode by episode
you reveal an extremely twisted show
nine-year-old diesel la torraca who
played austin miller
was stuck in the middle of all that he
played a character who not only suffered
from mental illness
but with absent parents fraud and even
homicides
yikes georgie meet pennywise
pennywise scares us can you imagine what
seeing the clown would do to someone who
was
nine well it actually didn't scare
jackson robert scott
as much as you'd think jackson played
the adorable georgie who was involved in
some
highly graphic scenes like these i was a
little bit scared
because i didn't know what he was gonna
look like
we can never forget this bone-chilling
hunger game
scene jennifer lawrence is amazing but
willow shields
is the one who really impressed us in
this moment at just 11 years old
she was able to portray such a
heart-wrenching character in primrose
a child who has lost her father suffered
through hunger
and now the reality that she might lose
her life or lose her sister
just trying to win if you can
name one person you know who didn't
absolutely love arya stark in game of
thrones
arya and her actress maisie williams
were a fan favorite during
all eight seasons of the show but what a
lot of people don't realize is that
maisy was only 12 years old when she
became the dangerous assassin
and wore the faces of the deceased
yeah gross but as maisie has said
arya was the assassin everyone's rooting
for
that was really interesting because that
doesn't really happen much in our
storyline
usually hollywood casts actors that are
older than their teen characters
but for pretty little liars alison's
actress
sasha peters was just 12 years old when
she was cast
while the rest of the liars were in
their 20s her age is the reason why
sasha wasn't cast as hannah instead
they were able to get away with some
pre-teen friendly scenes in the
beginning
but we can all admit that alison was
getting into some mature situations as a
teen
that we can't believe sasha played off
and i think the fans are gonna be really
happy with what happens with our
characters
we still haven't gotten the image of the
bent neck lady out of our heads when we
saw her in the haunting of hill
house so how was seven-year-old violet
mccraw
also known as young nelly able to film
that without being absolutely terrified
the truth is while there were some
pretty graphic scenes she got through
like the passing of nelly's mom they
made things on set for her seem fun
and always knew the ghosts were actors
but she
still wasn't able to watch herself in
the final cut
you're scared i can tell how cause i'm
scared
trying to comprehend being kidnapped and
locked underground
is tough for most adults let alone
eight-year-old jacob tremblay
jacob took the character of jack in the
film room in stride
and totally had us all believing he knew
what it was like to be held in captivity
for his
entire life he was able to grasp the
content
so well that the director credited him
for making the movie as successful as it
was
we're hoping his critic's choice award
is still proudly next to his millennium
falcon
i also want to thank my parents and i
love them very much
shameless does not lack r-rated content
this comedy series is definitely meant
for adults
however that didn't stop them from
having a very young cast
including 11 year olds ethan kotkoski
and emma kenny who played characters
debbie and carl gallagher
they were right smack bang in the middle
of it all often times being involved in
these scenes
but emma says her parents didn't allow
her to watch the show until high school
my childhood experiences and i don't
feel like i was
neglected of any of that which i'm happy
about a quiet place is one of the 2000s
creepiest horror movies
and 13 year old actress millicent
simmons was a part of it all
not only does her character witness the
passing of two family members
but overall she deals with horrific and
graphic scenes
involving the alien monsters scenes we
couldn't even imagine dealing with today
the adorable sunny power was only eight
years old when he filmed lion as the
young version of suru
just the premise of the film alone tells
you how mature sunny must be for his age
saru was separated from his parents at
such a young age and then suddenly taken
from his home and adopted by an
australian couple
these actors and their mature acting
jobs are really all the proof we need
that age
is just a number in fact dare we say
some of these actors are the reason why
their projects were so successful in the
first place
which actors age were you most shocked
to find out about